I mentioned health tourism okay here's a
fact and I'm sure that other people will
be mortified that I dare to talk about
it there are 7,000 diagnoses in this
country every year for people who are
hiv-positive which is not a good place
for any of them to be I know
but 60% of them are not British
nationals you can come into Britain from
anywhere in the world and get diagnosed
with HIV and get the retroviral drugs
that cost up to 25,000 pounds per year
per patient I know there are some
horrible things happening in many parts
of the world
but what we need to do is to put the
National Health Service there for
British people and families who in many
cases are paid into this system for
decades
thank you Leanne wood this kind of scam
and having hunger in practice that is
dangerous it's dangerous it divides
communities and it creates stigma to
people who are ill and I think you are
ashamed of yourselves well I'm sorry
we've got to put our own people per
watching would you Lee Ann would you Lee
Ann open it up to 17,000 Oh
27,000 people don't it the question is
how do we fund the NHS and it was up to
2 billion pounds a year is being lost on
health tourism surely that is a today
you know Nicholas sir when somebody is
diagnosed with that dreadful illness my
instinct is to view them as a human
being not consider what country they
come from if I were to go back to
something ed Miliband said earlier and
he said there should be